alors j'aimerais qu'on passe à ce garçon
facile à résumer et c'est une émission
de télé il semble très bien on forme un
groupe s'appelle Ellin Cup
Otis
Matt Pokora et toi et là plein de types
qui cartonne je crois notre étoile et
tout ça ça part la tournez pas les
unités machin et là tu utilises c'est
bon je suis arrivé Matt Pokora s'en va
fais une carrière solo ça cartonne pour
lui et toi les maisons de disques
prennent un peu moins bref ça prend pas
alors que tu chantes bien quelle
explication j'en sais rien comment tu le
vis
au début c'est un peu compliqué donc je
le cache pas j'ai envoyé plus d'une
quarantaine de titres chez M6
Interactions et Universal c'est à dire
que j'ai pas attendu qui me donne les
titres donc je suis allé chercher moi un
petit peu à droite et à gauche des
mouvants ce musical de l'époque j'aimais
bien la variété donc je suis allé moi
enregistrer de mon côté et à chaque fois
que j'en ai des titres moins chez M6
interaction et chez Universal je sentais
que c'était pas la priorité donc quand
tu sens que tu es pas la priorité que tu
balances un deuxième site un troisième
tu arrives à 40 j'en ai 40 à la maison
j'ai enregistré 40 titres que personne
Michael Jackson on peut ressortir des
épées 4
6 et
je le voyais et je sentais que j'étais
pas la priorité à un moment donné tu es
fatigué tu es épuisé et là tu commences
à partir en dépression ce que j'ai fait
combien ça t'avait rapporté tout ça les
chansons les linkles 70000 € en tout et
pour tout donc une fois que tu as et
puis j'ai tout ton argent et dans un
studio je ne sais pardon parce que je
t'ai tourné tu es dans un studio tu as
plus d'argent on s'intéresse pas à toi
et là c'est dépression bah ouais c'est
la dépression en fait si tu fais le
calcul on donne 70 000 €, on dit ça
s'arrête toujours au lendemain donc tu
dois vivre avec ça et on t'impose de pas
prendre le métro parce que on va faire
des singles prochainement on t'impose de
prendre le taxi on t'impose d'avoir un
train de vie qui va en adéquation avec
la célébrité et on te dit voilà il faut
que tu fasses ça mais en fait tu fais le
calcul 70000 euros sur deux ans ce qui a
continué les deux ans qui ont continué
juste après les Linka ça fait 3500 euros
par mois et tu dois vivre avec ça en
fait on dit ne fais pas autre chose que
ça et là tu dis humain quand tu es là à
faire le cheval de salle et qu'on reçoit
Matt Pokora qui est là qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait non je suis passé à autre
chose je te le dis honnêtement math que
ça fait maintenant 20 ans j'ai eu 10 ans
de psychothérapie
je vais je continue toujours à aller
voir ma psy parce que pour faire le
boulot que je fais là parfois il y a des
moments où je suis pas heureux ou je
suis pas je me dis j'aimerais bien
chanter j'aimerais bien jouer au théâtre
mais en fait je fais mon boulot je serre
le public en fait je serre le public je
serre les animateurs je vais faire les
chroniqueurs et il faut avoir une force
morale à l'intérieur il faut vraiment y
aller et je remercie et je fais un petit
coucou à tous les chauffeurs de salle
parce que c'est des pièces maîtresses
des émissions et faire ce métier là
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande vous arrêtez
même Matt Pokora lui-même dire pardon on
n'était pas pote on a créé un groupe
tout ça c'est pour ça qu'on se voit plus
c'était un truc de casting voulu en
voulez pas de pas le fait je ne lui en
veux pas parce qu'il a raison dans le
fond en fait d'avoir dit de dire ce
qu'il a dit il a dit dans une émission
on a porté ça m'a un peu choqué
de dire en fait ça a été que 9 mois de
ma vie et quelque part c'était rien
c'est rien pour moi c'est juste le
tremplin si on fait pas un numéro un
parce que faut pas se mentir tout le
monde dit les Linkup ça a été très court
ça a été 750 000 disques vendus j'ai un
triple disque d'or chez moi on a fait
toutes les émissions possibles et
imaginables que ce soit M6 TF1 et Hit
Machine tu peux pas dire ça ne m'a pas
servi et ce n'était rien et quand tu
sais que tu as fait 10 ans de thérapie
il prend pas je n'en veux pas du tout je
juge pas il prend pas le téléphone tu
entends pour dire comment ça va vous
faire un feat toi
il est dans un autre monde et je le et
et je le comprends il a une autre vie il
est passé dans une autre stratosphère on
a on n'est pas dans le même monde moi je
suis heureux je vais dire honnêtement
Mathieu quand je viens là et que je vous
vois tous on discute vous êtes humain et
j'aimerais pas être à sa place parce
qu'il doit avoir des contraintes
financières et doit préparer une tournée
ça doit être compliqué pour lui je dis
pas que c'est c'est s'il a pas une belle
vie mais quelque part tu dois gérer des
tournées il faut que ça continue à
marcher quel âge tu as aujourd'hui j'ai
45 ans et tu m'as dit un jour on est de
faire un documentaire ensemble tu me dis
je suis heureux depuis un an oui je suis
heureux depuis un an c'est à dire depuis
l'âge de 42 là ça fait ça marche pas
quand on est tout quand on est tourné
j'avais 42 ans et je t'ai et et je suis
venu après je t'ai dit oui ça fait un an
que je suis heureux oui donc là
maintenant franchement ça doit faire
trois quatre ans que je suis heureux
parce que j'ai fait une psychothérapie
et j'ai eu la force et le courage
combien de personnes qui ont fait des
émissions de téléréalité musicale qui
aimerait juste être là à ma place là
maintenant aujourd'hui gagner le salaire
que je fais et attention je travaille
encore je fais le tour du monde le
weekend dernier j'étais à ok
mais la lumière peut faire très très mal
c'est pour ça que je vous ai dit que
aussi les jeunes gens